hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
according to david hume in section 4 of
his inquiry regarding human
understanding and this is a theme that
runs throughout the vast variety of his
works all of our reasonings about what
he calls matters of facts so anything
that's not just relations of ideas
pretty much everything that we know
about the universe and ourselves all of
these reasonings involve some
understanding or reliance on the
connection between ideas that he calls
cause-and-effect we're always using some
reference to that whether we realize it
or not and so if that's the case he says
well we've got a little worried that we
need to think about which is well what
is cause-and-effect going to be itself
founded on and this is really important
because he says by means of that
relation alone we can go beyond the
evidence of our memory and senses so if
we want not just to carry out sort of
you know some logic stuff in our head or
arithmetic or geometry and we do want to
go beyond what we're immediately sensing
right now or what we remember that is if
we want to rely on the testimony of
other people or our imagination or
analogizing or anything like that if we
want a coherent world that we live in
perhaps also self understanding of our
own mental processes and our passions
well then we've got to have cause and
effect and if cause and effect is kind
of shaky then we've got a problem and
this is oftentimes where a lot of
discussions of Hume end they say well
you know Hume under behind
cause-and-effect now we get you know
absolute scepticism Hume doesn't think
so
and if we go on further we'll see that
he you know addresses this
satisfactorily he tells us all of our
reasonings concerning fact are involving
this it's constantly supposed that there
is a connection between the present
fact and that was is inferred from it
were there nothing to bind them together
the inference would be entirely
precarious and he gives them an example
the hearing of an articulate voice and
rational discourse in the dark assures
us of the presence of some person why
because these are the effects of the
human make and fabric and closely
connected with it because if we
anatomize all the other reasonings of
this nature that is if we cut up and
analyze these reasonings we shall find
they're founded on the relation of cause
and effect in this relation is either
near or remote direct or collateral so
then he goes on he says if we would
satisfy ourselves concerning the nature
of that evidence which assures us a
matters of fact we must inquire how we
arrived at the knowledge of cause and
effect what is it based on so there's a
couple different options here one option
is well we have some sort of a priori
structure that we bring to it maybe
there's some ideas in our head of cause
and effect like innate ideas so he says
I venture to affirm as a general
proposition which admits of no exception
that the knowledge of this relation
cause-and-effect is not in any instance
attained by reasonings priori so it's
not something that we derive from
considering relations of ideas it's not
something that we can know apart from
our experience in the world as a matter
of fact he goes on to say in that very
same sentence that it arises entirely
from experience now he's making a little
bit of a stronger claim than he needs
two there and it's a little bit
misleading I think because people
imagine when he's saying that that there
isn't some sort of like connection
between what it is that we do know and
what we can be certain about and then
these matters of experience that we're
putting in it's as if the matters of
experience are the entire building
blocks but let's see where he's going he
says when we find any particularly any
particular objects our
constantly conjoined with each other
that's the experience that we're talking
about constant conjunction is this
experience of one humans going to call
the relation of causality so he gives a
nice example here and he's given many
others like this throughout his works
let any object be presented to a human
being ever so strong natural reason and
ability so if somebody's got no
cognitive defects whatsoever if that
object be entirely new to that person
that person will not be able by the most
accurate examination of its sensible
qualities to discover any of its causes
or effects and then he uses atom here
atom though his rational faculties be
supposed at the very first entirely
perfect could not have inferred from the
fluidity and transparency of water to
sensible characteristics that it would
suffocate him that it would drown him
right and humans actually onto something
here there are so many cases where
knowing something about a thing that
doesn't mean that we actually know the
other qualities of that thing until we
acquire enough experience we live in a
world as a matter of fact where because
of our use of technology we have managed
to make all sorts of things that are
quite different than what we would
expect sometimes with hilarious
consequences sometimes with really
horrific and tragic consequences so I'll
give you just a few examples there's you
know candy that you can get and you have
no idea how sour with this candy will be
until you pop it in your mouth and you'd
normally don't a candy sweet right but
we've we've had an industry that is
competed with each other to make the
more sour puckering kinds of delicacies
right on the other hand think about how
children quite often get injured by
drinking or pouring on themselves
household
pickles which are often poisonous or
caustic or damaging in in other ways and
we could go on and on and on by simply
knowing the thing we don't automatically
know what all of its effects are going
to be until we acquire experience
another example of this there's bushes
and it was flowering right and there's
caterpillars that if you touch it's
going to really mess you up
and how do you find that out well by
doing it and of course if you're a
stupid kid the way I was your parents
probably told you see that mousetrap
over there leave it for the mice don't
mess around with it because if you touch
it it's going to hurt you and then I had
to learn the hard way that when you poke
at it and it does snap on your fingers
yes it does indeed hurt so there's a lot
of examples that we might have he goes
on and he says this proposition that
causes and effects are discoverable not
by reason but by experience will readily
be admitted with regard to such objects
as we remember to have once been
altogether unknown to us since we must
be conscious of the utter inability
which we then lay under for telling what
would arise from them and he it gives it
an interesting example from natural
philosophy about putting two blocks of
smooth marble together you wouldn't
imagine that they would be actually be
hard to pull apart but it turns out that
they are right and we could come up with
all sorts of other examples Hume seem to
be quite fascinated with these you know
the explosion of gunpowder the
attraction of a lodestone or magnet so
he goes on and he tells us that you know
the general idea here is that we cannot
predict her and for solely from our
ideas we have to learn what causes and
effects are by having experience in the
world by experiencing those sorts of
items as a matter of fact we could
experience things that are similar to
them but aren't exactly the same and
that might not actually help us he goes
on and he says this has to do with laws
of nature
you can't derive them a priori just by
sitting and thinking and
side your head you have to have a
resource of experience to draw upon in
order to even make sense of them and the
operations of bodies he loves the
example of billiard balls human
apparently liked to play billiards it's
quite a bit I thought it was very
relatable pool is what we call it here
you hit one ball it collides with
another it transfers its motion there's
no way that you would know that it would
do that right and he provides us with a
number of considerations or as he calls
them reflections if somebody wanted to
say no no we're getting our ideas a
priori from relations of ideas we don't
actually need to experience cause and
effect he says okay then let's think
about a few things here and there are
five main considerations that he brings
up he tells us that he says we're any
object presented to us and were we
required to pronounce concerning the
effect which will result from it without
consulting past observation after what
manner I beseech you must the mind
proceed in this operation it must invent
or imagine some effect which he
describes to the object is it sort of
its effect right so the mind he says can
never actually find this effect in the
suppose it caused by the most accurate
scrutiny and examination why because the
cause and the effect are actually
different from each other
the effect is totally different from the
cause he says consequently can never be
discovered in it motion in the second
billiard ball is a distinct event from
motion in the first nor is there
anything in the wand to suggest the
smallest hint of the other and he
actually has another great example where
he says you know eggs are really similar
to each other but you know we know that
they taste different from each other you
can't just say well one billiard ball is
like another they're distinct things he
also says that when you examine your
mind and the idea
the same thing goes for the tie or the
connection what we call the causality
connecting together cause and effect you
can't find an idea and they can
experience that actually is of the
causality of that connection between
them all you have experience of is this
happens then this happens you don't have
the and they're connected together
experience that you can bring to light
so you don't have any Opry or II idea
here that you can actually work with the
other thing that he brings up which is a
really important point is that assigning
causes to effects if we were doing it
solely a priori would be completely
arbitrary right how do we know that
anything would would work the same way
we from you know one effect we could
surmise a whole bunch of different
causes or from a cause a whole bunch of
different effects so he says every
effect is a distinct event from its
cause it could not therefore be
discovered in the cause and the first
invention or conception of it a priori
must be entirely arbitrary right another
thing that he brings up is that people
might say well you know we understand
these general principles about how
physical things work and it's
interesting let's pause for a second
here all of his examples are billiard
balls and you know things like that but
humans also very interested in the
passions of the human soul what we call
psychology right passions are emotions
and other effects and we could say
similar things with these as well you
cannot reason a priori about the causes
of these particular passions you have to
have experience with it as well so he
tells us we don't really understand
certain general causes the ultimate
Springs and principles he says are
totally shut up from human curiosity and
inquiry and what what are the ones that
he means elasticity gravity cohesion of
parts communication
emotion by impulse these are probably
the ultimate causes and principles which
we shall ever discover in nature and we
may esteem ourselves sufficiently happy
if by accurate inquiry and reasoning we
can trace up the particular phenomena to
or near to these general principles but
we don't actually understand how they
work as well all right and then there's
one other thing you might say well okay
that's that's all fine but we do have
some things that we do know a priori
that is without any experience and we
can work out a lot in these fields of
logic geometry arithmetic mathematics
more more generally and Hume says yes
that's true
but as soon as you start to apply these
to real things every part of what he
calls mixed mathematics
he says proceeds upon the supposition
certain laws are established by nature
and our operations and abstract
reasonings are employed either to assist
experience for the discovery of these
laws or to determine their influence in
particular instances now we're still
relying on experience the part of of the
applied mathematics or mixed mathematics
that is purely mathematical we can say
yes we know that completely we
understand how that works as soon as it
starts being applied to the realm of our
experiential reality we're now within
the the realm of this cause and effect
and we can't be entirely sure that the
mathematics that we're applying are
completely accurate
we can't ever really know that we've
measured something perfectly we can be
reasonably certain and we can be
reasonably certain that things work out
according to certain equations but they
also might not so that's not going to be
particularly helpful that's kind of
putting the proverbial cart before the
horse so what this means according to
him is if if we can't base our
understanding of cause and effect which
matters of fact are reliant on on any a
priori reasonings just on their own but
we have to have some experience
experience is going to be absolutely
central as the basis and that comes with
certain commitments and restrictions
you